Octopuses have been around.
And the current is full and far on 200 million years.
And if we are the most neurologically complex
versus an animal, they are the most neurologically complex in invertebrates.
So it's a completely different form of intelligence.
It couldn't get more different between an octopus and a human and Yext.
Somehow there are things we can relate to in one another.
Okay. Peter, let's settle this right out of the gate. I have one octopus.
I have two.
No octopuses octopus is, I know we went through this last show, uh,
when we were describing what's coming up on this week's show. Um,
not only is, uh, octopus, correct? I know you're in the octopi camp.
Yes, I am. Not only does. OC is octopus is okay.
It's actually the correct, uh, pluralization of octopus.
Not that I don't trust you or believe you, but I felt the need to double check.
So I hit the old magic box. Everyone's double checking me. And, uh,
apparently yes, grammatically speaking,
the plural for octopus is octopus's
as the Miriam Webster dictionary points out,
people use three different terms, however, octopi,
octopuses, and octopodes
while octopi has become popular in modern usage. It's.
It's a mistake. It is a mistake. The defense rests, your honor.
So I'm not going to lie. I don't like it. Uh, you know, when you know,
you've been saying, you've been saying something for years,
and then you got to say it differently. It feels odd,
but for the kids out there, plenty of kids, uh, fans of, of the,
what if videos we want to make sure our grammar is correct. So I will,
I will respect the proper pronunciation and I'm going to go with
octopuses. What else do you know outside of the proper pronunciation about
octopuses?
Well, what do I know about them? I, I just learned, uh,
earlier we course we know that they have eight arms.
I used to say eight tentacles, but that's not correct.
An octopus has no tentacles. Octopus has eight arms. Uh,
they shoot ink at predators as they're running away as a defense mechanism. Um,
and after watching the Netflix hit documentary, my octopus teacher,
I know a whole lot more than I ever did.
As do I, uh, nocturnal hunters made crabs.
I don't know why I would've assumed they were vegetarian or,
or cause they're soft. Yeah. You just would've thought they eat like,
like that sort of microbial, uh, you know, um,
what do they call that? A krill or something like that? No, they're, they're,
they're taking down lobsters and crabs.
Like they're straight up carnivores. Uh,
as far as in the art of camouflage, they make like chameleons look like,
like peacocks, like these guy, like they're not just changing colors, you know,
they're adding shells to the whole, I mean, it was,
it was wild to see the level to which they also are able to
blend in with the rest of the ocean.
Yeah. But in the end,
I think why this movie has resonated with so many people around the world is,
and why octopuses have fascinated people for so long? Uh,
you were talking a while ago about thinking they might be from outer space. Yes.
That's not confirmed. Um, but they are crazy smart. And uh,
dare I say, emotional strategic affectionate.
Well, I mean, this is, and just, it also,
hasn't been disproven that they're familiar. They have three hearts, come on.
There's something going on here. But there were stories I,
this kind of got a lot of coverage. I think, I dunno, maybe it was last year,
whatever there was, there was a, uh,
an octopus that escaped from a, an aquarium.
Like literally it wasn't just that it escaped there. Like it was on camera,
you know, you could see it. And I actually, I pulled it up here. It was,
the octopus was called inky. Yeah. Please try harder. Like,
come on, man. Um, the inky,
the octopus escaped from a New Zealand aquarium,
which some called the Shawshank redemption. Oh, not me, others,
others did. Uh, and that, and that, you know, there are no bones.
So they were, you know,
they're able to get through these really incredibly small spaces,
just like in Shauna's. Exactly. Um,
and they could also survive an hour out of water,
which helps that type of escape,
but it was the type of thing that people started to really wake up to hearing a
little more about, wow, octopus are really smart and they're sneaky,
but they can also, then there was videos of them like opening, like they were.
In unscrewing screwing caps and it learned the guard schedule. I think
it's just like.
Fantastic. Um,
but what we don't know,
I guess outside of this is what if an octopus
was your teacher?
Well,
I would say who better to ask them the director of the Netflix movie,
my octopus teacher PIPA early-ish
Pippa early-ish is a natural history filmmaker and award-winning environmental
journalist specializing in the field of Marine science and conservation early.
She is an accomplished diver and has worked with some of the world's top Marine
researchers and underwater photographers.
And he's the editor of the acclaimed photographic book, sea change,
primal joy, and the art of underwater tracking PIPA. Welcome.
To the show. So great to have with us today on what if discussed?
Thanks so much for inviting me guys. I'm very excited to be here.
So we were talking just sort of in the opening about kind of what this means
that a movie like this has, has,
has blown up as the kids might've said once, um,
in a way that it has, because, you know, I,
I don't know what your expectations were,
but the fact that this has resonated with so many people,
for the reasons that I think are, are good.
And part of the actual story of this beautiful connection,
it has to feel pretty good.
Yeah. It feels, it feels overwhelming, very overwhelming,
um, and shocking in some ways, but deeply,
deeply reassuring, uh, that people are resonating with the story.
Because
I think something that we don't talk about match and something that's really,
really worrying in the world today is we can see that we're
treating our panics in a way that is very, very bad for everyone and very,
very bad for everyone that's going to come after us,
but we never really questioned how we got here. And honestly,
I think our disconnection, our emotional, psychological,
spiritual disconnection from the natural world is one of the greatest threats
that we face and possibly the one that's spoken about the least.
So the fact that people are resonating with this phone, uh,
makes me feel extremely hopeful. Yeah.
I would agree with that. I mean, that's a good way to put it,
actually that disconnect allows you to sort of commodify things and
separate yourself from an and clearly what we see in my octopus teachers
connection that reminder that we're all kind of from the same place for just
process wise, because there's, you know, there's a lot of moving parts here,
obviously, uh,
Craig and his team are we're filmmakers.
This project had been going for a while when you come in at some point.
So give us a little background of kind of where you come into this.
A long time ago, Craig actually gave up for making, uh,
as we say in the full he'd completely burnt himself out.
He wasn't enjoying it anymore. He'd worked too hard for too long. Uh,
it wasn't bringing him the meaning that it had previously, I suppose.
So he just put down his camera and never wanted to go into an edit suite again.
Um, and he moved from Cape town,
the city they lived in and he moved down to the coast, uh,
and started going in the cold every day.
And there was only kind of a few years into swimming every day that he picked up
a camera again. Um,
and then a while into that process that he met the octopus. So,
uh, he is a filmmaker, but he wasn't setting out to make up for this.
This, this was a spontaneous thing that happened.
He just fell in love with this incredible what ecosystem and
was completely kind of his curiosity just got the better of him in a way
he is so passionate about this place every morning.
He's excited to wake up and see what he can find. Um,
and he is a photographer and he is an ISIS.
So documenting that process came very naturally to him.
And it had some points that that kind of feeling came back in him
that he went in to make a phone.
And it actually took a lot of time before he realized that it was his
experiences with the octopus, um, that has been very powerful to him. But,
uh,
I think he didn't immediately consider while this is a story that we can make
into a film.
He was just looking at all sorts of things and more traditional natural history
scenarios as well. And
I met him in 2015.
I went for a dive with a friend of mine called rice.
Who's one of the co-founders of sea change project.
And we were going to die with no way to switch. I was nervous about,
and I've been diving in capes on at that point for at least eight years.
So I didn't expect, I didn't expect this to be a groundbreaking experience,
but I can tell you that the minute that we got to that shoreline,
I started seeing this environment in a way that I never dreamed was possible
because Craig notices details and patterns
that allow you to get close to the culled forest
in a way that is impossible, if you haven't dedicated all the time that he has.
Um, yeah. And then I didn't see him for a very long time.
And in 2016 I'd been a science journalist for a long
time. And I've been working with Marine biologists all over the world.
And I had an incredible job.
I was flying all over the place and photographing sharks and rising about
shark biology. Um,
but I became a little bit despondent about the fact that I was missing all of
these incredible people who had stories about nature and about
experiences that they had with nature and deep,
deep understanding of the animals and places that they were working in.
And my experiences felt quite shallow and vicarious.
So that was why I asked Craig if I could start swimming
with him and diving with him. And if he would teach me something about tracking,
um, and it was only six months into that process that he said to me one day,
look, I'm going to make this full. And then would you like to help me.
Pippa? It's mentioned in the film that, uh,
we know very little about the octopus and as we found out, it's called octopus.
Vulgaris what, uh,
did you know about the octopus vulgaris before you started this film and then
what did you come out of this?
So I went into this phone knowing that an octopus had
eight tentacles
and can change color and just Kevin.
And that was kind of the depth of my understanding.
The very first thing I learned is that octopuses don't have any tentacles at
all. They only have arms.
So that's a common misconception.
And two feet. It seems like we saw two feet.
Yes. Sometimes they make two feet,
but they're actually walking on their arms even then. Uh, yeah.
And I came out of this foam after spending many,
many hours under water with octopuses. Uh,
one of the early things I learned to do was,
was learn how to track them and find where they lived. Um,
we're doing a whole lot of research about them and,
and to understand how octopus has fit into our world from an evolutionary point
of view is very,
very helpful because what you need to realize is somewhere
around four or 500 million years ago,
we and artifices where a similar kind of worm type thing.
And then we broke off into the vertical red line and they broke off into the
invertebrate line. Yeah.
So around after this is have been around in its current form
for around 200 million years.
And if we are the most neurologically complex
vertebrate animal, they are the most neurologically complex in vertebrates.
So it's a completely different form of intelligence.
It couldn't get more difference between an octopus and a human. And yet,
somehow there are things we can relate to in one another.
Well, which came out obviously beautifully emotionally, but also,
I don't want to say intellectually, that might not be the right word,
but you mentioned clever. And, and to your point, I mean,
I think there is some common, uh,
understanding that there's a higher level of, of let's say intelligence here,
but we literally see, uh, in the,
in the film without giving too much away, especially as it pertained to the,
the, the, the relationship,
maybe the wrong word here with the predators in the environment,
we saw strategy, like we saw adaptations to, uh, Oh,
okay, well that happened this time. I'm going to have to do this.
And in a relatively short period of time. Yeah. Like, I mean, it,
it seemed strategic. Is that a fair? Is that the right word?
Yeah, they are definitely strategic and they are strategic
intentionally.
And then they're also strategic from an instinctive point of view.
So these octopuses have lived in this cult forest for millions of
years now.
So they have developed all kinds of defense mechanisms for dealing with
creditors and, and it's an incredibly creative to danced environment.
There are sharks everywhere. Um,
I think something like 30% of the octopuses we see are missing alum.
So they, they're having a hard time surviving that kelp forest. Um,
so they've come up with new strategies and it lives somewhere in their kind of
species consciousness and emerges when it needs to,
but individual animals also learning along the way. Um,
and you see how the Kesha octopus kind of
develops inability to deal with scavengers that are
coming into a space when she's caught, you know, what the, the,
the brittle stars, for example, you saw how at the beginning,
she didn't know how to catch lobsters. She tried and she tried and she tried,
and she almost seemed to get frustrated and eventually she figured it out. Um,
and one of the most fascinating things for us is,
I don't know if you can see that,
but you see that little tiny hole in the end of that shell.
So this is something that was explained to us by professor Jennifer Mathur,
who came out and was the scientific advisor. Um, she's one of the,
world's only octopus psychologists.
She spent most of her life trying to get into the mind of cephalopods and
she gives them and a whole lot of these shells.
And what you sometimes find is there'll be two or three holes with animals
failed before they got in. And what that means is, uh,
that they're trying not getting the hallway in or not getting into the right
parts of the animal that they're trying to kill.
And then they have to try again.
So they almost have to learn a kind of geometry.
And once they learn how to do it, every single time they go back,
they tend to get it right. And like they said,
there's a drill on the end of one of their arms. Is that how you put it?
It's not on there. It's not on the end of their arm. It's like inside the beach.
And it is a drill and sane.
Army knife in there. I mean, uh, but it was just, I mean, it was good.
And again, I mean, that's a big part of the movie, right.
We learn a lot of different things. Uh, but also, uh,
the lifespan, I didn't know. I, and I don't think it's a spoiler. I mean,
I think it's going to obviously come up, but why,
what is the lifespan of an octopus and why was that
important in, in sort of the narrative of this film?
So different species have different lifespans, um,
the giant Pacific octopus,
which lives kind of on the coast of Canada and California lives for up to three
years, but our little octopus,
vulgarness coming up to the slips for around 18 months.
And it's very important. It's quite extraordinary, really.
You realize how quickly they have to learn and how much they learn in a very,
very short space of time. Um,
and obviously Craig,
you that his time with his animal was limited. Um,
I don't know how much he was thinking about that during the time that he was
with her. Um,
but a lot of the stories is bittersweet because you kind of get the sense that
the end is coming. Um,
and also in terms of a evolutionary strategy,
the short life span is really,
really interesting because their whole breeding cycle revolves around that. Um,
octopuses, when they, once they made, uh,
the males kind of die and the females climb inside the
den and lay eggs and they stay there quietly and they blasted on the eggs and
they keep them clean and they keep them safe from scavengers,
huge portion of their body mass goes to creating my eggs.
And by the time those babies hatch, they
are at the end of their life. A lot of them are almost senile at that point.
And that's where you see this very, very sad ending to the film,
but what's really fascinating is scientists have done pretty hardcore
experiments where they've cut a nerve
in the octopus brain after they've it.
Uh, and once that nervous,
severed the octopus kind of doesn't go into this behavior where they dedicate
themselves to the eggs and they can live for twice as long. Wow.
Yeah, that's incredible.
So in a way they're literally sacrificing themselves for this,
this new generation of octopus.
And you also have to kind of wonder if they didn't have such a
short lifespan and they learned as quickly and grew as quickly as they do.
I think we could have a problem.
Yeah. They'd be in charge down there, possibly up here or up here.
Yeah. Um, PIPA one of the cooler things I saw, but apart from the, you know,
the death cycle, but one of the cooler things that we saw in, uh, in the film,
and I think a lot of people know how octopuses can change their selves to
blend in to their surroundings,
but there was a whole new type of blending in that we saw from this octopus.
And maybe you can tell us a little about that.
Yeah. So we all know that octopuses can,
can change the color and texture of their skin. Um,
they can make it smell spiky. They can make us foods that, um,
there's a lot more to it than that. They, I mean, Jennifer professor,
Jennifer Matha describes it as octopus language and they do have some
really, really genius ways about smarting animals around them.
Um, and a lot of that strategy revolves around trying to say,
trying to pretend to be something other than an octopus.
So sometimes you'll see, they'll make really, really dark,
huge eyes that makes them look 10 times bigger than they actually are.
So their eyes will be black and their body will be wide.
Sometimes they'll move in a different way,
such as a scene where she's walking along the sea floor or pretend to be a rock
and then slowly move as they're being the rock.
And then you saw the scene where she turned into an old lady with the dress and
the times,
and there is a shot in the phone where she like twelves on her legs up into
little towers and stretches herself into this very strange position.
That's an octopus,
just not wanting to look like an octopus because some things made it feel a
bit uncomfortable and all it knows is it doesn't want to look by something that
can be equal. Remember,
this is an animal it's a snail that slice its shell.
So it's highly, highly intelligent, but also incredibly vulnerable.
So that's why it's hard to become so clever.
And, and, and quickly like, that's the other thing, like, I mean,
you would think it would take a lot of brain power to mimic something and to be
able to do that in a year,
a measure of a human could do learn this much in shape-shifting Pippa.
We've got a lot more questions about under the sea and octopuses and things like
that.
Are you able to stick around and join us for a few more questions on the other
side? Perfect. Before we go, before we, uh,
leave the video viewers,
maybe you can tell us what is the sea change project and how can people get
involved?
Okay. So the sea change project is a group of divers scientists,
storytellers. We're all based in Cape town,
on the shores of the great African sea first.
And the great African CFRs is this incredible underwater forest that stretches
from Namibia, uh,
on the West coast all the way around to a place called the hook in the East.
It's about 1300 kilometers of coastline and it's an
exquisite habitat. It's also a very, very healthy habitat,
at least as far as the cult itself is concerned. Um,
but it's a place that hardly anyone's heard about before this film.
I think very few people had ever even seen images of South Africa called forest.
So really what we're trying to do is make it an ecosystem that's known
and make it an ecosystem with nerves and people's imaginations.
So that if at some point there is a dire threat to it,
or is it some point there's an opportunity to push through legislation that
supports its protection or supports the return of some of the big reef,
the species that have been fished out. For example,
we can get the support that we require from both the South African permanent
and the global public.
Well, it was a beautiful place. I'd never heard of the sea forest, myself,
the kelp forest, myself, and a, if you haven't seen my octopus teacher,
make sure you go out and watch it on Netflix.
Thanks very much PIPA for joining us.
We'll hear more from Pippa on the other side and the audio podcast,
the extended audio version, click on the link below. Uh,
but otherwise thanks very much for joining us.
Thank you so much.
So yes, as we, as we often do on the show, and as we often talk about,
we've learned a lot, anybody that's, that's watched the movie,
my octopus teacher would have learned probably more than they ever would've
expected to know about an octopus, but more importantly,
I would argue were moved. They were affected. Um, they, they,
they came out of that experience. I think not just with more knowledge,
but what they care, right.
Which was a huge accomplishment for them with this film.
The octopus, but what I really took away.
And it was right in the very beginning.
And I think they probably wrapped it up very nicely at the end of the film as
well, is that it all started with, uh, Craig's journey, um,
trying to get closer to the earth and trying to be more connected to the earth.
He saw the hunters in the Kalahari being able to track something and he
realized, I don't know how to track anything. And in this film,
we ended up learning how to track an octopus. So he actually got to do that,
but just imagine if we all were more so connected to nature right now that we
could just like, look on the floor. Oh, I can tell that there was a mouse there,
you know, 10 hours ago and I can follow it and figure out where it is.
Like if you had that ability, we've all lost that connection.
We're such a disconnect. And, and unfortunately, uh, as you.
You sort of touched on there what ultimately got him to do that,
was he proactively sick? No, he was burnt out and yeah, really,
unfortunately often what is the, you know,
the only thing that's going to drive people to reconnect with nature
in that way. That's so like,
I wish I could say it in a way that didn't sound trite, but it's,
it's literally vital to like, if you,
if you talked to any scientists who studied human behavior, happiness, it's,
it's, it's not just a luxury to say, you know, you gotta be connected.
It's vital part of us that especially people who live in cities and in urban
environments, they have that.
So little of that connection it's reflected in every part of our health that we
don't necessarily. So you almost have to push yourself in his case.
He was pushed. He did this out of the fact that he was kinda,
he was checking not, I don't want to say checking out, but he was,
he was burnt out.
Yeah. He really was. Um, you, you say people in cities,
maybe more so than people in countries, but, uh, I'll tell you,
I grew up in the country and I was not as connected, you know, you know,
a lot more about what's happening around you, then people in the cities do,
but you're still not connected to like, Oh, where that's a, this is a Fox,
unless you're a Hunter perhaps. And you've learned that, um.
It's an intimate relationship like that requires and teaching and some sort
of relationship. And interestingly, you know, this,
we talk obviously a lot about science on what if discussed.
And of course this is a film that's been for the most part,
I think entertaining for people in different ways.
But I would argue it has to be the most comprehensive research
study scientifically of an octopus in history.
So there's value to that as well. I'm sure. I don't know if they have a relate.
I mean,
we talked with the sea change project and what's going to come out of that,
but this really has to almost change the game and what we understand now about
octopus.
Well, we, I mean, you're seeing thing yeah. To push this,
you're seeing things that you've never seen before. And you got to ask yourself,
ask yourself why, why have we never seen that before?
Because people haven't gone down there and studied it as closely.
Like you'll when you watch the film,
you'll see things that you've never seen before from an octopus in a nature
documentary.
And this guy Craig was down there sounds like pretty much every day
of the octopus, his life from, from the time that they met, maybe like 80,
80 to a hundred days into it. Um,
but basically we saw the octopus on a daily basis.
And I don't think that's, I'm guessing that's not been done in science.
This might be the most comprehensive study. Like you say, of an octopus.
And an incredible, you know, just an incredible endeavor PIPA talked about,
you know, how this kind of came together, how long it took plenty of stuff.
I want to get into a little more of that with her. Because again, it's just not,
uh, it didn't just roll out of bed and do this, this that, you know,
there's a bunch of stuff that had to come together here. And of course,
as she talked about,
they never in their wildest dreams could have expected this level of impact.
Never could. And if you're watching the video, podcasts also will join Pippa.
On the other side here, if you're watching the video podcasts,
this is the end of the video podcast.
So if you want to hear more with our guest Pippa, early-ish, uh,
why don't you click on the link below here on the YouTube? Uh,
that'll take you to the extended audio version. Now,
if you're listening to the audio version,
you're also listening to the extended audio version.
You don't have to go looking around for anything else you're already there.
So if you want to learn more about world under the sea,
how to befriend an octopus.
Um, and my octopus teacher, the film, my.
The film. Well, why don't you click on the link below, uh, if, uh,
if that's all too complicated and you just gotta go, well, thanks for watching.
And you can join us next time on what if discussed?
[Inaudible].